[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24 ya
está conmigo en el estudio más romeros a
la mar el ayuna es una práctica común en
esta época del año en muchas culturas
hablamos de semana santa la pesa el
ramadán
exacto raúl muy buenos días pues este
ayuno está asociado a muchísimas
religiones como decías aunque son
distintos no en el ramo sodio es más
largo semana santa se recomienda por
ejemplo en unas pocas pero unas pocas
semanas o en viernes santo como sea pero
básicamente
todos tienen en común que hay está dejar
de ingerir comida como una práctica
espiritual veamos qué sucede en nuestro
cuerpo cuando eso cuando hacemos eso
cuando dejamos de comer o estamos en
periodos de ayuno en general eso
significa que el cuerpo deja de absorber
energía de manera constante a través de
la comida y de sus nutrientes y que por
lo tanto tiene que sacar energía de
otros lugares ahora veremos cómo eso
significa que cambia el proceso
metabólico que es cómo se produce la
energía en nuestras células implica una
cierta reducción del ritmo al menos en
lo físico sin embargo en los casos de
ayuno agudo como el ramadán por ejemplo
dejar de comer sobre todo al principio
puede provocar una cierta mayor descarga
de adrenalina un estado de mayor
atención mental también de más energía y
es precisamente la combinación de estos
dos factores que puede hacer que haya
influido tanto en el ayuno como una
práctica espiritual de meditación de
reflexión no también de más de atención
como decíamos mental además pues de lo
que implica en términos de disciplina
del cuerpo que en muchas religiones
suele estar asociado a lo material claro
marco en los impactos entonces que tiene
el ayuno en nuestra salud pues depende
mucho del tipo de ayuno no sobre esto
por ejemplo yo quería hablar del ayuno
intermitente que es una especie de como
de de moda podríamos decir que se ha
hablado de muchísimos beneficios que
tiene ha habido un boom de estudios
también de cobertura mediática pero
entonces vamos a repasar bien cuáles son
esos posibles beneficios haciendo una
búsqueda rápida incluso en google en
estos medios de salud y de nutrición
vimos que se habla de que regula la
insulina que rebaja el colesterol que
incluso puede llegar a prevenir
enfermedades neurológicas como el
alzheimer también que puede ayudar a
tener una vida más larga e incluso se
habla de prevención del cáncer vamos a
ver qué hay detrás de todo esto no por
un lado es normal que ingerir menos
comida ya que haga que tengamos menos
azúcar en la sangre y también menos
grasa que es la insulina el colesterol
por otro lado y un proceso que se llama
la inflamación crónica que tiene mucho
que ver con comer alimentos procesados y
que está relacionada con ciertas
enfermedades como la diabetes el
alzheimer o incluso la artrosis
reumatoide que el ayuno puede hacer que
al menos en un corto plazo disminuya
esta inflamación y por último también la
autofagia un proceso descubierto sólo en
2016 en el que las células lo que hacen
es cómo digerir ellas mismas sus propios
residuos o basuras celulares este
mecanismo se activa con el ayuno y pues
se cree que puede estar relacionado por
ejemplo que esa basura celular puede
estar relacionada con el alzheimer o con
otras enfermedades neurológicas se sabe
que tiene que ver con el proceso del
envejecimiento y también se cree que la
autofagia puede ayudar a impedir que
ciertas células sanas se conviertan en
cancerosas sin embargo eso no significa
que sea una certeza a día de hoy se sabe
que hay una relación entre todos estos
factores pero no se sabe bien cómo opera
bueno yo hablamos de los posibles
beneficios por ahora hablemos de los
riesgos exacto no pues para empezar hay
unos sectores de la población para que
en el ayuno está claramente
contraindicado hablando por ejemplo de
personas embarazadas que estén en
procesos de lactancia enfermedades
hepáticas personas con diabetes puede
ser que tengan que consultarlo con un
doctor sobre todo en casos de diabetes 1
y por supuesto personas con trastornos
de conducta alimentaria precisamente de
eso nos alertaba la doctora paola
sabogal nutricionista a quien
entrevistamos puede tener una incidencia
importante en el desarrollo de conductas
de riesgo tipo atracón compulsión
alimentaria o patrones muy parecidos a
la bulimia nerviosa no como el ciclo de
restricción y compulsión alimentaria que
terminan en atracón y esto es
encontraban adolescentes en estudios de
cinco años como te digo entonces hay
algo importante ahí que tenemos que
tener en cuenta y es que en personas que
tienen algún riesgo de desarrollo de
trastornos de la conducta alimentaria
que hoy en día pues es una masa grande
de personas por la normalización de las
conductas de riesgo y si vamos a
encontrar que tiene un efecto importante
en el desarrollo de ciclos de atracón y
por acá
y restricción como tal
la doctora mencionaba estos cinco años y
es que muchas dietas que se ven que
fallan con este periodo de 5 años y
faltan sobre todo eso muchos estudios en
como el ayuno puede influir más a largo
plazo no en unas semanas o en unos meses
sino realmente a largo plazo eso la
verdad todavía no lo sabemos claro mal
por entonces que se puede hacer para
prevenir estos riesgos del ayuno pues
para empezar no hacer ayuno si a seúl si
se hace bajo presión por ejemplo o si no
se tiene claro si se puede hacer no es
impensable entonces empecemos diciendo
eso pero segundo por ejemplo hay un
apunte interesante que nos hacía también
la doctora y es que en este ayuno como
práctica espiritual puede ayudar a
reducir estos riesgos por ejemplo
trastornos de conducta alimentaria por
el hecho de ser una práctica social y
ritual escuchemos
gran parte de las formas en que se ha
practicado el ayuno digamos por mucho
tiempo ramadán en culturas religiosas ha
estado muy relacionado con formas de
autocontrol de la voluntad pero de una
voluntad que va muy desde la
espiritualidad no la voluntad que
tenemos hoy en día que es el control que
está muy como desde el ego y control y
de la sociedad en que vivimos sino una
voluntad que realmente de domesticar es
ver desde la espiritualidad que viene
acompañada de muchos rituales en general
que además están en esta comunidad que
están poniendo sedes de otros lugares
que el comer cuando se hace el acto de
comer es un acto compartido
eso nos puede indicar por ejemplo que
hacer este proceso de ayuno en comunidad
de manera acompañada con un objetivo
distinto por ejemplo el de la pérdida de
peso y acompaña de alguna práctica
espiritual o grupal en el sentido más
amplio de la palabra puede ayudar en
parte también nos puede ayudar pues
aprender a comer bien más allá del ayuno
no y presentarnos si para lograr nuestro
objetivo es necesario ayunar o solo es
necesario pues tener una mejor dieta y
sobre todo tratar de tomar decisiones
informadas revisar estos estudios mirar
en cuánto tiempo durarán si son animales
en humanos cuántas personas tuvieron en
cuenta entonces tratar un poco de tomar
el control también sobre qué decidimos
hacer y no dejarnos siempre llevar así
es más buscar la mejor solución lo que
se adecue más a nuestro cuerpo y también
de la mano especialista gracias mar como
siempre por toda la información nos
vemos el lunes con más nosotros
continuamos y pasamos a saludar a
nuestro segundo invitado el día